[Music]  pack your bags up TV we're going to make  enough Lindsay Lohan's return to reality  TV is officially a go get ready lilo  shared a teaser announcing the show on  Monday the series tentatively titled a  Lohan Beach Club will they be you on MTV  sometime next year people have this  image of me that it is chaos I don't  want all of the negative that's going on  Lohan appeared in a self-titled  docu-series 4 owned back in 2014 but  this new show won't be as focused on the  starlet from what a source tells ET  expect a more glamorous Vanderpump rules  [Music]  the series will place Lohan in the Lisa  Vanderpump role advising a group of  brand ambassadors as they help to launch  her newest nightclub in Greece the 32  year old already operates two other  hotspots in the Mediterranean I want to  focus on what I what I really feel I  want to do right now and I think that's  important to me  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]